hello and thank you for the introduction
it's an enormous honor to be here um as
I as Adam said I've been asked to tell
my story of how I started working and
thinking on food and how this thinking's
evolved over time as a way of linking
and raising some of the the big issues
that we're going to be discussing today
and i'm going to emphasize the story bit
because food is about stories the grand
themes of life and death excess and
insufficiency pillaging and plenty and
it's also app that I focus on stories
because what kicked off my way into food
was studying English literature at
university now literature is full of
different people's visions of humanity
and their potential and what today will
show is that the different things that
people say about food and that reflects
their visions the stories that we tell
ourselves about who we are and where we
should be going and one thing about
studying literature is that you need to
know a bit about the Bible to read much
of Western literature because it's so
strong in shaping our literary metaphors
and mindsets and I speak as an atheist
but right at the heart of not just the
Christian myth but that of many other
religious traditions is a garden of
abundance and plenty from which we've
been exiled and that myth as well as its
counter myths have a very strong
resonance within the environmental
community today which is worth bearing
in mind so my story I read literature
which was frankly not great for job
prospects and then I did a masters
followed by some voluntary work in India
where I realized exactly the scale of my
own insignificance so I decided to come
back to the UK look to my own backyard
and got very interested in some of the
ideas of the alternative food movement
and I got started to work for a small
NGO where I set up a project they looked
at urban agriculture and which will be
may be hearing more about today which
spoke to my enthusiasm for urban utopias
about how we could link health and
vibrant communities and greener cities
and at the same time I also got really
interested in climate change which was
becoming more and more topical and
the environmental movement was talking a
lot about food miles seeing them as the
arteries of evil globalization with its
attendant ills including carbon
emissions and I wanted to think more
about this so I moved to another NGO
where I set up a project which was
started ostensibly to look at at food
miles and to campaign for more local
food but then I started talking to lots
of people and and I started to think
hang on is shorter fewer less distance
actually better what happens when you
think about the mode of transport air vs
shipping and what if something is local
but kept for ages in energy using cold
storage so and around this time I came
across some quite early studies a lot of
them by Swedish researchers that were
looking at impacts carbon in pattern on
the whole food chain agriculture
processing refrigeration cooking waste
and and that these could have bigger
impacts and transport and that could be
trade-offs between one stage and another
and I realized it was tremendously
complicated but also really important
because it seemed that the food system
had these massive impacts on climate but
there didn't seem to be an organization
that was set up to look at these issues
in the round how does food contribute to
climate change and what can we do to
reduce them so I thought well wouldn't
it be a good idea if I set up a network
to do just that so that's what I did I
set up the food climate research Network
which is now at Oxford and looking about
I was hugely naive I didn't know my
nitrous oxide for my nematodes I had no
idea that food was so politicized and
but I have learnt I have learned a lot
about that and and I think what's for me
my understanding and that of the food
climate research network in many ways
mirrors the changing preoccupations and
insights of the many different
stakeholders within the food movement so
we've moved on from just asking how does
food contribute to greenhouse gas
emissions and how can we reduce them to
recognizing the importance of what we
eat as much as how we produce on these
impacts with rising understanding of the
importance of meat and realizing that
different ways of producing and
distributing and
foods reflect health environment jobs
animal welfare power relations in very
different and often conflicting
contradictory ways and we've shifted
from talking about a food chain to a
food system that brings in people and
institutions and power relations so I
think where we are today is that we all
agree we have massive problems that we
need to solve but people prioritize
these problems differently and they
disagree about what we ought to do and
so I think that's where we are we all
want a greener fairer healthier food
system who could possibly disagree but
people's different vision of what this
looks like what good actually looks like
can differ quite wildly because I think
when we talk about Catalan corporations
trade and transgenics plates and planets
when we analyze our problems and propose
solutions there is a subtext that runs
through the stories we tell and the
arguments we make and that subtext is
really about other things like our
relationship with nature what is it can
we integrate with it should we what is
the legitimacy of modifying our
environment as opposed to adapting to it
what about ideals about scale is big
better or small sustainable what's the
balance between individual freedom and
collective responsibility how immutable
a culture tradition pleasure and is
growth necessary or should we simply
strifer enough for Lagaan as you Swedes
stay and if we had this balance would we
actually want it and I think ultimately
perhaps the deeper questions that we are
debating are these can technology save
the day and more fundamentally should it
if the problem is us our human nature
and the social structures that reflect
it will technology simply open the doors
of one prison into a larger one so is
the priority to change ourselves and
which approach the technological or the
radical or the or the societal is the
more radical
so I returned to the garden of eatin are
we actually exiled and either way are we
doomed or are we free to forge a new and
better world over to you
[Applause]